yeah ello welcome to this video and this
is slightly different video I mean it's
just a five-minute game but there's a
small detail in this game because if you
look at my my text here my name it
actually says international master so
feat of only managed to get this
paperwork issue soft and they really
gave me this toddler so I'm glad that
this has finally happened this is the
first game which actually displays this
title on video so really nice ok so now
link to this game here we got down
benoni here unknown yeah it's sometimes
called the Schmidt pannonia from low
Tosh meet the German I'm Grandmaster who
is very famous mostly on for his role in
the official Spassky match the match of
the century very was the arbiter and he
had really as hands full obviously so we
gotta be known am I tried with bishop
age 16 exchange has some strong bishop
which I really like to do in those so
benoni setups this piece is just just
strong and it's good to get rid of it
and he has managed to advance here on
the queenside so I'll exchange this and
play 93 the IDM to maybe place tonight
on c4 he already has an ID on be 60 this
is not such a huge problem for black he
can just swap this night off ok so now
he tries to to close the position or
provoke me to take only six which I'll
think i will do I don't think this
closed position promises me so much so
I'll take and the question is some what
about this t6 pawn now is he able to
advanced this without any any huge
difficulty so rookie one would be a
normal-looking move here to put pressure
on this on this pawn yeah I think I'll
do it looks very safe also but he might
play the five long so the question is
some is there something better now then
taking I guess not right so let's
capture him and yeah this is actually
interesting he took with the Queen so it
could I could also just move the Queen
now with the discovery on this Queen
over by the rook so Queen III for
instance or some other Queen move is
there some really great Queen move that
I can do Queen FY maybe just place Queen
at five maybe Queenie 3m keeping an eye
on the c5 pawn and I'm not sure yeah you
can go here but then I have Bishop d3
with a gain of tempo yeah I think I'll
do that now back to to f6 so I could
actually take c5 now ok b2 is also
hanging but i think its positioning on
look slightly loose here so just rugby
one
or is there some some better move I've
also have moves like Rooker a six or a
seven it's hard to determine what's
what's better Knight d4 also also might
be something to consider but I'll play
this first and see where he goes with
this Queen and no way actually he just
takes my queen but wow
if i do queen 85 what is he doing Quinn
85 I'm attacking the night how does you
protect it queen adria player okay one
or does it just play okay no but I don't
have to check it out and let the check
all right so so I can just wrap this
right there are some some trick that
don't see it so I just want this piece
unexpectedly ok now let's get rid of the
coins alright so only chance is so its
own the time or some some blunder by me
but I really hope that I don't think
that I won't spoil this first
international master came here on five
minutes played a couple of bullet
yesterday when I got the message that I
that I have the title but he simply
doesn't want to resign you just
blundered another look
what now letting the clock run down what
kind of guest is anyway is so I am as
well but no no further info I guess some
said some secondary account it doesn't
have a name in there if you got and got
them a title here on a cc like
international master upwards you can get
one account value for free where you get
your name in there like like I have half
the name in there and you can get one
anonymous account so this is one of
those anonymous accounts I guess where
it just says p.m. but but no name and I
can't believe it he just lets the clock
run down for two minutes now oh well so
what whatever i'm about to do in those
two minutes um i had a similar situation
in in a video well some guy let the
clock run down like two minutes and i
suggest that i could play some music but
this might be tricky with copyrights so
i won't play any music sand someone
actually suggested that I should sing
myself and I won't sing I promise you I
won't ever sing on a video this wouldn't
end well maybe by my neighbors would
turn up in some sort of lynch mob and
kill me and I don't know you might have
a lot of years or something after
listening to this so i won't sing I
promise yeah well he takes a sweet time
I really hope I mean it looks like some
some kind of um weird behavior not like
like I'm disconnected or something no
but my connection seems perfectly a ride
um I just got one of those yeah what can
you do I won't insult him if you want
you can in your in your comments but
yeah what else is there I did I did
those some videos in German for for the
Dortmund tournament
I think they were quite well received
among them the German audience it was
sort of a project that that I started
together with with a website deep chess
dot de German language side so it was
clear that the videos should be in
German also and they lifted the guys
later who do the website they live quite
near to me so it was some sort of a
project among friends so grant forfeits
on time now we really lost some time it
was sort of a project amongst friends
and it's not planned to do a German with
us regularly on the side I'll staying in
english so i might do a development
recap in english also i'm not quite sure
the thing is that those some german
videos really takes some time to produce
and i simply don't have so much time if
you if you spend like two hours each
evening to do this this german video you
don't have much time for anything else
but i might do a recap after the
tournament and i've been some
interesting games alright so thanks for
watching and i'm glad to to finish this
w game on the five-minute pool as an
international master with the wood but
yeah mo no comments on on the opponent's
behavior at the end all right yes see
you soon with new videos